let's go to Mike from Florida Mike from
Florida please save us let's hope your
audio device is configured correctly so
that we can all hear you and we can get
this going in a way that makes sense sir
welcome
David packman yes hey can you hear me I
can hear you fine
wow pleasure to speak to you likewise
guess I had a small observation sure and
if I had any sort of question that would
be what is your perspective on that when
I'm done all right if that makes sense
to you sure so
I kind of asked myself in general why
does a person go towards being a
conservative or being a liberal okay
like
average person
they tend to gravitate towards one or
the other or be an independent but
like
how can someone watch something like say
Fox News or Newsmax and be drawn into
that
kind of
you know honestly I wasn't prepared
question today well this is a great
topic I think I I have a lot to say
about this so there's a couple different
things going on here Mike if I may we
know that there are some differences in
the brains of the average conservative
and the average liberal this doesn't
mean that your brain determines which of
the two you will be but there are some
studies that find that the
um fear centers of uh brains being
larger
predisposes one to be more likely to be
on the political right than the
political left things like maybe
something to do with dopamine like you
watch the person who is having some sort
of freak out on something you know some
contrived social issue and then you as
the viewer are like yeah that's right
and you feel better yeah I don't even
know the mechanism necessarily but it
seems that there's something that is a
physiological thing we also know that
it's very environmental people who are
raised in blue States in left-wing homes
are are mostly likely to be on the left
and people who are raised in in
Republican homes in red states are more
likely to end up being Republican so
there's definitely an environmental
component to it as well
be anomalous to that you know statistic
I was raised in a red home in purple but
Flora is arguably a pretty red State
these days yeah none of these are hard
and fast rules but these are just
predispositions and then thirdly and
this is the really this is the tough one
sure I believe that those
who do not receive education in media
literacy and critical thinking are way
more likely to fall for what Fox News
and right-wing media sells and are more
likely therefore to end up on the right
that was kind of like what I meant to
get at like Rachel maddowell I wasn't on
the air before but I was never like a
super fan Watcher every day just taking
whatever someone on the left says
without a grain of salt but it seems
like the kind of person who would be
predisposed to watching Hannity or
Tucker just unobjectively soaks in what
they say yeah you know for
I don't know maybe just like the
willingness to accept what someone on TV
is saying unpredictably that is
something you can be educated out of 100
yeah so Mike excellent question
complicated topic but I hope I gave you
some insights into it
now wonderful speaking to you have a
good day David all right Mike from
Florida great to hear from you remember
if you want to talk to me your nickname
in the uh waiting area needs to be name
and location and it needs to at least be
plausibly real okay so like it could be
a city or a state or if you're in
another country another country uh let's
go so so like nicknames and single words
and jokes and this type of thing will be
skipped over one of our sponsors today
is Bluetooth a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz on their
website a licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA the entire
process is just a few clicks go to
bluetooth.com the link is underneath
this video they'll give you an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code Pacman all you have to do is
pay five dollars shipping